[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hello, everybody.
How are we doing?
Good.
Awesome.
Fantastic.
Welcome to "Agones: Scaling
Multiplayer Dedicated Game
Servers with Kubernetes."
I hope this is the
session you expected.
Because this is where
you're staying, hopefully,
for a little while.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud,
specializing in games.
And I guess, technically,
founder of this project,
I think is probably accurate.
So we're going to talk today
about multiplayer games,
Kubernetes, containers,
and other good stuff
in that kind of arena.
Does that sound cool?
Sounds good.
Awesome.
I regularly give this
talk at game conferences,
so this is probably one of
the first times I've actually
given it to a wider tech event.
So I'd like to know a
little bit more about you,
and so I know my audience and
I can tailor appropriately.
So people here who work
in the games industry?
Ooh.
Actually more than I expected.
That's cool.
Awesome.
So people who work specifically
on multiplayer games?
Most of the same hands.
All right, awesome, cool.
All right, so very
many of you who don't.
That's certainly cool.
That's fine.
We're going to look
at some of that too.
People who are
comfortable with Docker?
Most of you, but not all.
That's fine too.
People who are comfortable
with Kubernetes?
Also not all of you.
That's also cool too.
All right, sweet.
All right, that gives
me a really good idea
of where we want to take
this and where we want to go.
Excellent.
So what are we
talking about today?
So the thing I
want to talk today
is about multiplayer games.
And multiplayer games is a
broad and far reaching term.
But I want to talk about very
particular types of multiplayer
games.
What I want to talk
about is your very
competitive, online, fast-paced
multiplayer games, right?
So your Unreal Tournaments, your
Overwatches, your Fortnites,
your MMOs, your Rocket Leagues,
games like that, all right?
Things where very
fast-paced things
happen between the players.
And they have very
particular needs,
and we're going to talk
about how we sort of cater
towards those sort of needs
with a project like Agones.
To do that, I'm going to
use an open source project
called Xonotic.
Anyone here played
or heard of Xonotic?
That is like the first
hand I've ever had go up.
So that's awesome.
Very happy.
It's a really cool
open source game
that has very traditional
like FPS-type gameplay, so
like Capture the Flag,
Deathmatch, things like that.
But it's great.
It's open source.
We're going to use that
as a demonstration of how
we can use that on Agones for
playing and scaling multiplayer
games.
Does that sound cool?
Cool.
So as you saw in the title, I
use this term "Dedicated Game
Server."
So for those of you who
aren't in the games industry,
this may maybe something
you haven't heard of before.
So let's talk about what
that actually means.
So there are a variety of
ways of making these types
of multiplayer games.
One of the most
prevalent was, especially
amongst very large
scale games, is
about what's called doing
a dedicated game server.
So a dedicated game server is
a full simulation of the game
that you're playing.
So like all the physics,
all the interactions,
between the players.
And all the people who are
playing said game interact
or directly connect to
that dedicated game server.
So usually they're
sending things
like, hey, I'm moving forward.
Please let me move forward.
Hey, I'm rocketing
because I'm firing
a rocket car or something.
Maybe I'm firing a gun.
Maybe I'm doing all
sorts of actions.
And I tell the
dedicated game server
what it is that I
want to have happen
That dedicated game
server will then actually
simulate what's happening
inside that system
and then pass out
what's true and what's
happening from that dedicated
game server back to the clients
so they can render
it to the people who
are playing the game.
There's a couple of very
good reasons for doing
this, one of which is latency.
So games that are
very fast-paced--
10 milliseconds 20 milliseconds,
30 milliseconds of latency--
can be a very big deal.
So having control over
exactly geographically where
these dedicated game
servers are sitting
in relation to the players
that are playing them
gives you a lot of control and
gives you a player experience
that you can rely on.
And this is a good thing.
We can't control
the speed of light.
It would be really
nice if we could.
So having that geographic
location-based system
is really, really
nice for the players.
On top of that, I might let
you in on a little secret.
I don't know if
you've noticed this,
but some people are
really horrible.
I don't know, maybe
you haven't noticed.
I don't know, maybe.
That's great.
And if you haven't,
that's wonderful.
But as soon as you hand
someone a binary with traffic
they can introspect,
people tend to do that.
They tend to have a look
at what the traffic is.
They tend to have a
look at the binary.
They try and play with it
and mess around with it.
Basically, they try and cheat.
Having a dedicated game server
that sits on your own network
can mitigate some
aspects of that too.
So that gives you some leg
up in that way as well.
We're not going to talk
about it that much,
but it's something to consider.
So dedicated game
servers are good.
And because they
mitigate cheating,
the idea is that
they're authoritative.
They are the source
of truth about what
is happening inside a game.
I say that I shot that
person over there.
It is the dedicated
game server's job
to say, hey, that actually
happened in the way
that you expected it to.
The way I like to think of
it is each of the client
asks to do something, and the
dedicated game server's job
is to tell this is
actually what's happening.
So cool.
We have a bit of an idea
about dedicated game servers
and how they work.
Awesome.
So traditionally, how are
these things architected?
So you might have, say, in a
typical session-based game,
like, say somebody is
playing like Capture
the Flag or something
like that, you
might have two more
people who are like,
I want to play a game.
So they sort of declare
they want to play a game,
and they're going to talk
to some kind of matchmaker.
That matchmaker
is probably going
to pair them based
on skill level, maybe
their social graph,
stuff like that.
And once they've got a pairing,
or a match, of some kind,
they're going to talk to
some kind of Server Manager.
This Server Manager's job is
basically to be like, hey,
you need a game server
to run on and then you
can all connect to.
So it will then talk to a
potentially very large cluster
of machines, potentially
spanning the globe--
be like, OK, this
machine's the good machine.
Also, we like this one, and
it's got enough resources.
Sweet.
Let's spin up a process on it.
Let's set up the game server.
We'll find a port that's free.
Fantastic.
All right, so now
we have an IPM port,
where, like, these games
are being played on.
Now we can send that back
up the pipe, all the way
up through the matchmaker
to those two players,
and they can make a direct
connection to the game.
Direct connections here are
important because of latency.
We don't want to go
through a load balancer.
Also, that full simulation
stated in there.
So we can make direct
connections and everything that
happens inside that machine.
So that's basically
how a lot of very
traditional big multiplayer FPS,
you know, very fast-paced games
work.
The part that I want
to talk about today,
though, is this part here.
This is where Agones
kind of comes in.
So we're not talking
about the matchmaker,
but what we're talking
about is the system that
says, oh, I need a game server.
But where in this
cluster should I put it?
Where should I run it?
That kind of stuff.
How do I spin it up,
how do I spin it down--
that kind of thing.
And this is really
the kind of problem
that Agones is trying to solve.
So Agones-- what we
were talking about.
Although apparently, if I say
it right, it should be Agones.
We should have a rolling
R. I've been told by people
who say Greek.
So this is an open
source project
that technically we
started back in November,
but we only announced
it earlier this year,
for running, scaling,
hosting dedicated game
servers for multiplayer games.
I'm pretty excited about it.
And I think it's really cool.
So I'm glad that you all
came here to hang out with me
today to hear all about it.
The thing that's really
cool about this as well--
we aren't doing this alone.
So this is a Google
Cloud-led project,
except for the fact
that we are doing it
with a wonderful
collaboration with Ubisoft.
They've really
brought to the table
their long term experience
in running multiplayer games
at scale, and they've been
doing it for a real long time.
And from the title,
as you see, we've
been building this
on top of Kubernetes.
We've been able to
build the experience we
have with running containers
and building Kubernetes.
And it's been a really lovely,
like, meeting of minds,
I feel like.
They're lovely people, and I
can't say enough nice things
about them, actually.
Sweet.
So let's actually get into
how does the thing work,
and we'll look at some
code, and how do we actually
make this thing happen, and
stop talking theoretical
and get actually practical.
Does that sound cool?
Yeah.
Awesome.
So potentially,
unsurprisingly, we're
going to talk about containers.
So we reuse a lot of what
Kubernetes gives us out
of the box.
So first step for taking
our dedicated game server.
So say we've written a
dedicated game server.
Maybe we've done it ourselves.
We've used Unity.
We've used Unreal.
Really, the first
step is basically,
we put it inside a container.
There's nothing really
special going on here.
But I want to talk
about containers
for a bit too, especially
those people who
aren't familiar with it.
So if you haven't really
worked with containers much,
the part that I find most
exciting, the part that I think
is most relevant here as well,
is that really, containers
are a standard.
They enable you to
take a set of software
and build an artifact
that is transportable,
that is runnable, all through
a standard set of interfaces.
So we use this analogy a lot
of, like, an actual shipping
container.
But I feel it's really apt.
So it doesn't matter whether
I'm running a game server
or running in .NET, or
C++, or Java, or Node.
I don't care.
It's in a container,
that's great.
In the same way with
a shipping container,
I don't care if it's a Ferrari,
or a whole bunch of chairs,
or, I don't know, table cloths.
I can pick it up
with the same cranes.
I can put it on the same truck.
I can put it in the same ships.
Everything is fine, as long
as it fits that standard.
And so this is true here too.
Because we can put a game
server inside a container.
We can put whatever we
want inside it, whatever
systems you need inside it.
This is our basic
building block,
and it means that we can do
very generic stuff with it
that we need to do
for both game servers
as much as we would for any
other types of software.
How do I get new versions of it?
How do I get my
[INAUDIBLE] out of it?
How do I know if it's running?
These are all standard
problems for everybody.
So to prove to you that I'm not
twisting your arm or anything,
this is essentially the
Dockerfile for running Xonotic.
If you haven't written
Dockerfiles before,
they're fairly imperative.
They have a series of
commands, we do them.
You start from the top.
Many of you have done this,
so this is probably not
new for you.
We start from the top.
So we say, hey, let's
start from Debian
to start from a Linux instance.
And then we download Xonotic.
And we move some files around.
Basically, Xonotic requires us
to put in this server_linux.sh
in the right spot so it will
run as a dedicated game server
instead.
And then we set an entry
point which basically
says, when you've created an
image from this Dockerfile
and you run it, run this thing.
There's nothing
really special here.
I just want to be
clear about this.
I am slightly hand-waving.
I'll admit this up front,
if people have actually
worked with Agones.
There is an SDK that
is built into Agones
for doing standard game
server lifecycle things.
It's one of the things it
gives you out of the box.
So hey, this game server's
ready-- health checks,
things like that.
I'm going to be hand-wavy
about that here.
We actually do some
wrapping stuff for Xonotic
because I don't want
to touch the code.
That's fine.
But that does exist.
But essentially here, this
is just a Docker container.
There's nothing special here.
We're not removing
any capabilities.
We're not adding anything.
It's just a standard
Doctor container.
So anything you can put in here.
So again, for those who aren't
as familiar with Docker,
once we have this
Dockerfile, we're
able to create a Docker image.
This is something we
can tag, we can version.
And then we can share this
around with a registry.
If you're not
familiar with Docker,
again, this is the thing
that lets you do, hey,
this is a new version.
I want this to go out live.
Who can grab a copy of this
if I download this image?
Is it the right image?
Is it the one that
I expect it to be?
That kind of stuff.
So all that stuff that
you have when you're like,
oh, I have a game server.
I would like to update it.
Those sort of problems
are essentially
solved, just by using
the standard tooling.
So nothing too special
there in the Agones land.
But I just want to set a kind
of baseline and that kind of--
that Docker knowledge.
So to prove to you
that it works--
if I can switch to demo, please?
Thank you very much.
I'm going to run my server.
So I'm actually running--
oh, we're talking about the SDK.
I'm actually running the
local version of the SDK here.
So I'm just going to
run this from here.
But to prove to you,
like, Docker run--
that's Xonotic running.
I know that doesn't
look like much.
But I just want be really
clear about something.
I didn't run the
specific commands
I needed to care about for
Xonotic, I just ran Docker run.
And that's really powerful.
That's the abstraction
I'm talking about.
That's really nice.
Because as long as I run
Docker run, my server runs,
everything is good.
That makes me happy.
Cool.
So that's super
baseline Docker stuff
but from a game
server perspective.
If we can switch back to the
slides, that would be awesome.
Thank you.
OK.
So we have a game server,
probably [INAUDIBLE] the SDK,
which is great.
We put it inside a
container, [INAUDIBLE]----
nothing too special.
But we don't want
just four players,
we want lots of players.
Lots of players, good.
For some reason, only having
one player or two players
doesn't pay the bills.
I don't know why.
But it would be nice if we
had lots and lots of players.
So this is where we step
into the land of Kubernetes.
So you've probably
heard this word a lot,
being here at Google Cloud
Next, which is not surprising.
If you're not familiar with this
at all, which is totally fine,
think about it-- the
most simplest way
I can ever explain Kubernetes
is that it is an open source
project for running processes
over thousands of machines,
or even less.
Just over big
clusters of machines.
If this sounds
familiar, compared
to what it is we were
talking about previously,
there's a reason for that.
Kubernetes is really
important to Agones.
And I want to talk about
it for a couple of reasons.
One, because it's kind of
amazing in what it enables
you to do, because out of the
box, it gives you things like,
hey, I want to run
these processes.
I want to run 10 of them.
Make sure they're up,
make sure they stay up.
Let me do log aggregation,
lots of really good stuff,
just straight out of the box.
The big thing that's really
important about Kubernetes
and why it's important as well
for games and game servers,
is it is an open
standard for basically
running infrastructure.
So you might come out of the
gate, and you're like, awesome.
I'm going to run my game
servers on top of Agones,
and we're going to
stick them on GKE,
and it's going to be awesome.
We're going to use Google
Cloud, and it's great.
And then you discovered that
in some pocket of the world,
you have a really
fervent player base.
And then you're like, oh,
well, Kubernetes is great,
but GKE doesn't
seem to cover it.
Let's look at some
other cloud providers.
Maybe they do, maybe they don't.
And then you're like, you
know what would be great?
It would be great
if I could just
set up a little colo
somewhere, buy some hardware,
put my game servers there.
Because then they're going
to have the best game
experience they can have,
because latency matters.
So wouldn't it be
great if I just
had a platform where I could
basically pick this up and put
this wherever I want?
This is what Kubernetes
gives us, which is amazing.
So Kubernetes is the standard.
You might come to us and be
like, GKE is great, awesome.
But sometimes I also want
to run on my own hardware.
Maybe I want to run GKE on-prem.
That's pretty cool.
I'm really excited
about that, by the way.
Or maybe I just want
to be able to put it
into particular places.
So once you have
Kubernetes, that
means that you can run
Agones on top of it.
And yeah, that gives
you the flexibility
to run your workload
for your games
and your game servers in
exactly the right place,
and it makes sense
for your players.
And that gets me
really excited too.
Because that means
that we can all play
better games, which
I like playing games.
I don't know about you.
It makes things fun.
So let's look at how this works.
The other part of what
Kubernetes gives us as well
is some really amazing
abilities to extend it.
So those people who are
familiar with Kubernetes,
you've probably
seen deployments.
You've seen services.
You've seen pods.
You've seen these sort
of nouns of things
that exist inside Kubernetes.
And you get into
the world of what's
called custom resource
definitions and controllers,
which is a term, if you
want to completely forget,
that's totally fine.
You get into this
realm where you're
able to add your own
nouns to Kubernetes
and tell it how to handle them.
So it knows how to handle
web server type experiences.
You do a deployment--
run 10 of them.
If one of them dies, don't care.
But what we want is we
want an experience that
works for game servers.
We want to be like, hey,
fire up this game server,
but let me know when it's ready
to accept player connections.
That's something I care about.
Make sure there's
health checking that
makes sense for a game server.
Before players have
connected, you can restart.
That's OK.
But once players are
connected, don't restart.
Because otherwise,
weird stuff can
happen when players reconnect
to game servers that
have zero state.
That's a little weird.
So stuff like that.
So we're able to extend
Kubernetes, both from a YAML
perspective, but it also
extends the backing API as well.
So I'm going to do
a bunch of stuff
here, as well, with
Agones that we're
going to use YAML, which is the
pretty standard way of doing
stuff with Kubernetes.
But anything you see me
doing with YAML and kubectl,
I can do through an API as well.
I can do it all through
the Kubernetes API.
So just keep that in mind.
Anyway, so if we want to
fire up a game server--
in this case, the Xonotic
game server, how do I do that?
Once I've installed Agones,
I can create this thing
called a game server.
It's really that simple.
How does that work?
So I say, game server.
I can give it a name.
I can also tell Kubernetes
to generate a game server
name for me, if I want.
That's just part of Kubernetes.
And then I've got very game
server specific things,
like what ports do you
want to open on this so
that I can connect to it.
Now, we do direct connections
with dedicated game servers.
That's something that Kubernetes
gives you out of the box.
This is something that
Agones will handle for you.
So we'll do allocation
of ports for you
so that you don't have to
worry about that yourself.
We do that port routing
as well for you--
make life nice and easy.
So we do port management.
You get multiple ports.
And then we can do
a set of containers.
So here, this is the game
server container Xonotic 0.3.
For those of you who are more
familiar with Kubernetes,
what's available
here is actually
a full pod spec as well.
So anything you
can do with a pod,
you can do inside
Agones as well.
So if you want to
do volume mounts,
secret mounts, config
management, all that stuff,
that's all available--
multiple containers, et cetera,
et cetera.
For those of you not so
familiar, don't worry about it.
You can run a container.
So here, we're running
the Xonotic example tag,
running out of the Google
Cloud registry here instead.
And so this gives us the
ability to run a game server.
So if we can switch back
over to demo, let's run one.
Does that sound like fun?
Awesome.
So here, I have
up top weavescope,
which is a great visualization.
I'm going to install
Agones first.
We have a helm chart
for that, although you
can use install YAML.
Let's see if I get this right,
helm install name=agones,
namespace=agones system.
Cool.
Install helm agones.
Whew.
I think I got that right.
So it should spit back
a whole bunch of stuff.
See my internet works, good.
That actually looks right.
That's good.
It should show me a
controller at some point soon.
Go on, I saw something happen.
There we go.
OK, so that's up and running.
So that's basically
me installing Agones.
It's not particularly
complicated.
Pretty straightforward,
which is quite nice.
And now, everything's available
to me to run a game server.
So let's just have
a look at pods here.
I'm going to go into the default
namespace, which is where I'm
going to create my game server.
So I'm just going to
do a kubectl apply.
So this is going to apply
the game server configuration
we saw previously.
So what am I doing--
I'm doing examples Xonotic.
And I want it to run
as a game server YAML.
So we now have a game
server that's been created.
And you'll see that it says
the word game server there.
What's really cool,
if you've never
looked at any of this
extension stuff--
I can say get game
server, for example,
and it understands
what game server is.
I can even describe
this-- this is
going to show a bunch of stuff.
Game server-- and it will
give me code completion
as well, which is also nice.
But I'm not going to
look at that right now.
So we can see that
Xonotic's running.
If we want to, we can
have a look at its logs.
There's a bunch of
stuff happening, great.
I can see there's a bunch
of messages coming out.
So that's all up and
running, which is lovely.
If I describe-- I can see
there's a bunch of events.
We get a bunch of status data.
Oh, my god.
That's really hard to see.
OK, so we're not going
to do it that way.
Here's a cute thing
that I really like.
Do you ever want to use
kubectl and get custom columns?
I really like this.
You can do your own
kubectl commands
that give you custom columns.
So this gives us a
really nice thing.
So when we fired
up our game server,
Xonotic's going to fire
it up, allocated a port.
So we can actually
have multiple ports--
that comes out of the map.
And it'll give us
the IP address.
the status as well.
When a game server is ready,
it marks itself is ready.
So it's good to go.
So that's cool.
We can fire up our game server.
That's pretty neat.
It gives us an IPM port.
We can see that it's running.
But we can do more than this.
So let's actually
delete this game server.
GS is just the shorthand
for game server.
And we'll come back
over to the slides.
Can we come back over
to the slides, please?
Thank you.
Excellent.
OK, so we can do more.
But let's just
have a quick look.
So we saw the
previous architecture.
We're like a couple
of players who
want to play with a matchmaker.
So maybe we have a custom
matchmaker, possibly
the new open source
matchmaker that's
coming out later this year.
That would be cool
that we're doing.
And instead of talking
to some Server Manager,
we instead talk to
the Kubernetes API.
And we can say, Kubernetes API,
please create me a game server.
And Kubernetes is declarative
like this, which is nice too.
So we tell it what we want,
and it goes ahead and does it.
We would like a game server.
Create one for me, please.
And it'll do that.
It'll create a dedicated game
server, send back the IPM port.
We can send that
back up the pipe.
And our friends can play again.
But like I said, we can do more.
Sometimes, in fact,
often times, we
don't want to fire
these up one at a time.
What we want to do instead is
have a large group of them.
So very much like if you've
used Kubernetes before,
instead of having
just individual pods,
what we really want
is a deployment.
So what we have
instead is we also
have what's called a fleet.
So hey, I would like to have
a pool of 100 game servers,
please, that are
all up and ready.
And then when the player
wants to play with them,
I would like you to pull
one out of the fleet
and hand it over to me.
And then I can set players
to play their games,
so that I don't have to wait.
That would be sweet.
And then I can keep track
of what's in the fleet,
and I know my players are
doing, and everything's good.
And there's some
other cool stuff
that we'll look at in here too.
So if you have ever
played with deployments,
this probably looks
fairly familiar.
This is just another extension.
So we have a fleet.
It looks like a game
server, except we just
specify how many
replicas we want,
and then we specify what we want
our game server to look like.
So here we have two, and
we have a game server
that looks pretty much
exactly as it was before.
Nothing really different,
other than we're
specifying that we
want lots of them.
Cool.
But you may be asking a very
interesting question, which
is a good question indeed.
We don't have load balancers.
How do we pull a game
server out from this set
and be like, I would like
one of these, please.
Can I have one, please?
So we have a thing called
a fleet allocation.
This is just one
way you can do this.
We have a full
API, so you can do
a whole bunch of different--
different types of workflows.
Just so it's clear.
But this is what we
prefer, at least right now.
So we are able to
say, hey, Kubernetes,
give me a fleet allocation
out of this particular fleet.
And it's going to respond with
a game server that is actually
marked as allocated as well.
This is quite nice.
So it will do all the management
of those game servers,
be able to look
through them all,
and be like, hey,
let's see if there's
one that's ready, and
available, and waiting for you.
And if there is, it's going to
pull it out and be like, cool.
I'm going to mark
that as allocated,
and then I'm going to
give that back to you.
Now, allocated is special, and
we'll look at that in a minute.
Let's head over to
demo land again,
and we'll play some more.
Excellent.
So let's fire up a
fleet so we can just
have a quick look at it.
We'll apply dash f
examples, Xonotic fleet.
And this is basically
exactly what we had before.
So I'm going to create two
instances of this game server.
We'll see if they come up
relatively fast, which is nice.
If we run that command that
we were running previously,
we can see there's two of them.
They're ready, they're
running on different ports.
They're running
on the same node.
That's fine.
That's cool.
OK.
And we can do very
similar things
to what we had previously.
Like, for example-- so I
know we have previously,
but if you use deployments, for
example, we can edit our fleet.
It's called Xonotic.
And we'll be like--
let's make that bigger.
If we were like, hey, I
would actually like 10,
we can make that happen.
For those more familiar
with Kubernetes,
at some point in the
near future we'll
make it so you
can kubectl scale.
It will happen.
But we've asked for 10.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah.
And there's a whole bunch
of them getting created.
Whee.
So we can scale these up and
down, which is really nice.
But let's allocate
and have a look
at exactly what happens when
we start allocating stuff out.
So we'll have a quick review.
So let's run this command.
So we can see they're all ready.
That's good.
And we have 10 of them, sweet.
So let's allocate.
So this is something you might--
we would probably end up
doing through a API command.
So you probably allocate
for your matchmaker
and be like, hey,
give me one, so I have
people who can play a game.
But for me, I'm just going
to show it to you with YAML.
If you ever want to get
the results out of YAML,
just do that.
It'll spit it back out at you.
It's going to spit out
a lot of stuff at us.
So actually, let's
make that bigger.
So that's because I
read the wrong thing.
That's fine.
We're running demos.
It's fun.
All right, we want
to create this.
OK, so I've got
that, that's fine.
We want to be
explicitly creative.
Let's do that.
OK, that's better.
All right.
So this is spitting
back all of this stuff.
Oh, my god.
It's so much.
So I'm going to
ignore most of it.
Spinning it back, we'll
see we have a status.
It gives us back a
game server right here.
But the bit that I
care about, really,
is this bit down here at the
bottom, where I say status.
So it's giving me
back the game server.
So we looked at that before
when I ran the command.
It gives us an IP address.
It gives us the port.
And it gives us the
state allocated.
This is kind of the big
thing, I think, with Agones
and with game servers.
And it's kind of the
tricky part about it.
We sort of talked
about it before.
So before players
connect to a game,
we don't care about
that game server.
So I could scale this
fleet down to zero,
and it would kill all
of them because there's
no players connected.
And that's great.
But as soon as we're
allocated, we're
assuming that there are
players connected right now,
and you do not want to
delete that game server.
Because for some
silly reason, players
get mad when you cut off
their game halfway through.
So let's try not to
make that happen.
And this is one
of the big things
I think Agones really gives us.
So let's actually-- I'm
not going to do that.
Let's allocate a whole
bunch, and I'll prove to you
that I'm not 100% lying.
So sweet.
We can see we have four
allocated, for example.
What happens at this
point if we want to scale
back down at this point?
So if we want to kubectl
edit our fleet again.
And what is it called, Xonotic?
There we go.
And we want to bring
this down to three.
That's going to
take a little while
because those game servers take
a little while to shut down.
Let's actually look at the
pods, which is like the backing
containers that are running.
We'll see that most of
them are terminating.
So these things
are shutting down.
But we still have
four that are running.
Even though we've told it
we want to go down to two,
it's going to go down to four.
And this also applies for when
you want to do updates as well.
So fleets manage
updates for you as well.
We're not going to
look at that today.
But say I want to have a whole
new version of a game server,
and I want to roll that out.
I can do that.
I can do a kubectl edit or
do an apply of a new version,
et cetera, et cetera--
usual stuff.
And it'll go, cool.
We're going to have new
version come through.
Excellent.
So it'll stop pushing
that version through.
But the game servers that are
currently connected and are
allocated-- it's going
to leave them alone
until they shut themselves down.
So this is really important
stuff, and kind of different
from how a lot of other
applications work.
So if we have a
look here again--
cool.
We can start to see this
is starting to disappear.
But we still have those
allocated servers,
and they're never going to
go away until we're finished.
OK.
Let's play a game.
That's kind of what
we're here for, right?
Video games are fun.
So let's grab one of these,
not the unhealthy one.
That would be bad.
Here we go.
Let's grab the top one.
Actually, I don't
need to do that.
I've got the IP address here.
So I've got an IP address here
for one of these on a port.
And there's a port open on 7791.
So let's pop over
here, run this.
And OK, that's going to pop up.
Well, we'll turn that
off because that's just
distracting.
Now, the other fun question is--
I can't see my IP import.
That's hilarious.
I didn't think of that.
Anyway, that's fine.
35917.
5.197 dot.
Well, we'll just
move this over again.
19742.
dot 36.
Did I type that right?
Nope.
197.42.
No.
Oh, my god.
I did not do this well.
OK, that's fine.
Kubectl describe
game server Xonotic.
This will put it on the left.
HD 8.
There we go.
Now I need to
scroll up a little.
Perfect.
I have done this once where
I actually took a photo of it
and then did it that way.
And it worked.
It was fine.
35.197.42.367791.
All right, litmus test.
Will this work?
Black screen is actually good.
I don't know why they
made the game that way.
Just to give me a heart attack.
So this is connecting
to a GKE server.
So like I said, we ran a fleet.
It fired it up.
It's found a port for it.
It's allocated to a particular
node in the cluster.
Here we go.
And given us a game server.
It's allocated itself as ready.
And now I have to
play on my trackpad.
And fine, come on.
There are like four other
bots in here somewhere.
Do you know something?
I don't think I've actually
played on this level before.
I'm playing.
Come on, just show
me another player.
All I want is like one other
player somewhere in here.
Of course, I can't
find a single soul--
literally, as soon
as I'm in front
of a whole group of people.
There we go.
Fine.
Yay.
All right, so here we are.
We're playing, we're playing.
So this is me running.
I've gone in on a cluster on GKE
that's somewhere around here,
on the East Coast
or the West Coast.
And so it actually works.
Cool.
So that's actually working,
which is also cool too.
Awesome.
OK, so let's move back to
the slides again, please.
Fantastic.
OK, so this is kind of cool.
This means that we have a very
similar architecture to what we
were looking at
previously, which
is spinning up game servers.
But now we have a warm
fleet, which is really nice.
So that means, then
when we run this thing,
we can say to Agones,
hey, we have this fleet.
Give me one of these
out of this fleet.
And it'll pull one out
of the fleet for me
with the appropriate locking
and the appropriate atomicity.
And we can send that
information back up,
and these people can
play a game as well.
But the nice thing
here-- and I kind of
want to highlight it
as well-- is these
are layers on top of layers.
So in the same ways
with Kubernetes,
if you're like, I
like pods, but I
don't want to deal with
deployments, for whatever
reason, or you want to do
something very specific,
we can do stuff.
If you're like, I don't
like the way fleets work,
you can interact directly
with game servers,
or you can manipulate fleets
in some very interesting ways
as well.
So we're trying to meld
that flexibility in.
You can do some
really neat things.
So where are we going in
the future with this thing?
So technically
today, I was meant
to put out the 0.3.0
release, because that's
where it is in the calendar.
Next got in the
way a little bit.
It should happen
today, I think, maybe.
But the 0.3.0 RC candidate
came out last week.
So we're on a six week
rotating release cycles.
That's working
out really nicely.
We have a bunch of stuff
coming, the next big ticket
items, statistic
collection and display.
So we want to do
very standard stuff,
like player count,
how many game servers,
how many game servers we had
over time, so that stuff.
But we also want to be very
game server specific statistic
collection and display as
well, so frame rate, hitching.
So we want to be able to
look at exactly what those
are-- very, very particular
things that you want.
We want to have those baked in.
Because basically, everyone
needs these things.
We're going to look
at auto scaling.
Auto scaling has some very
unique and interesting problems
to game servers as
well that are very
different from other things.
As we looked before, you
can't shut down nodes
when people are playing games.
They get mad.
So we need to look at
that, and there's also
some interesting
statistical stuff
that we can play with there.
We want to have some better
commercial engine integration.
So we've got a lot of interest
specifically around Unreal
as well for doing this.
And we're actively
working on that right now.
We've got SDKs for
C++, for Go, for Rust,
which actually got
dropped by the other day,
which was really cool.
But we've also opened it up now.
The whole SDK system
is built onto your PC.
But we've opened it
up to Rest as well.
So if you can send either to
your PC or [INAUDIBLE] JSON,
you can build an integration
that's pretty straightforward,
which is quite nice.
We are actively looking
at Windows hosting.
So Windows is pretty big
in the games industry,
strangely enough.
So there's been
some wonderful work
by a lot of people
who are doing work
with Kubernetes and Windows
that we're looking to rely on.
So we want to make sure that
that's as well supported
as we can make it as well.
Finally, all the
way down the line,
we definitely want to be
supporting multi cluster.
Sig Multi Cluster
is the group that
does a lot of the
multi cluster work.
So we want to make
it easy and available
for you to run multiple
clusters around the globe.
We also want to build
tooling into that as well.
So like, what are my ping
times from these clusters?
And these clusters
available, being
available to take them down
so you can do that round trip
time.
So you know what
you're latencies are
between the clusters.
Again, just standard stuff
that people are going to need.
So what did we do today?
Just to kind of wrap things
up in a nice pretty bow.
So we took our
dedicated game servers.
We were talking about that.
We don't care what
language they're in,
as long as they can interact
with their SDK, which
pretty much everything
can, which is great.
We stuck them
inside a container.
So we're good.
You can put whatever you want
in there, which is great.
It gives you the
flexibility to do
pretty much whatever you
need with your dedicated game
server.
Then we took that
container, and we stuck it
on top of Agones, which is nice.
So now we can scale this.
We can scale this out to
thousands of machines.
We can run thousands
of game servers.
So we can support lots
and lots and lots and lots
of players, which is good.
Because lots of players--
they like spending
money, which is good.
Do you want to learn more?
Agones.dev will
take you directly
to the Github repository.
We should have a
fancy new website
in maybe about a month or so.
We're working on that too.
Agones.dev on Twitter as well.
We've got a mailing list.
We've got a very active--
reasonably active slack
channel, where we like
to talk about this stuff a lot.
We are definitely
actively looking
for contributors in any
way, shape, and form.
So if you're interested,
come into Slack
and just be like,
hey, I'd like to help.
That'd be great.
For obvious reasons, if you're
interested in Kubernetes,
Kubernetes.io, et cetera on
that kind of stuff as well.
I don't know if you noticed
I wear this t-shirt.
It says something like Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
So I'd be remiss if I
didn't take the opportunity
to spruce that a little.
So if you find me at least
vaguely entertaining,
myself and Melanie Warrick run
a podcast called Google Cloud
Platform Podcast, where we
talk about all sorts of things
Cloud, including game
stuff, and so the Kubernetes
stuff, machine learning,
all sorts of other stuff
along those lines as well.
I will reiterate.
If you do have questions and
you don't get to them today,
my business cards are
sitting right there.
So please feel free to
come up and grab some,
and come swing by.
My DMs are open on Twitter.
You can hit me up on
email, anything like that.
So if you don't
think of anything
at this particular
point in time,
I'm open and interested
in hearing your opinions
and questions.
Finally, thank you very much for
coming and hanging out with me
today.
I know your time is valuable.
And I appreciate that you
decided to spend it with me.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]